arriving at the Alis Palace for a
conference on humanitarian aid for Gaza
hosted by French president Emanuel mro
world leaders and heads of Aid agencies
among them Palestinian prime minister
Muhammad who set the
tone how many Palestinians must be
killed for the war to stop is six
children every hour enough is four women
killed every hour enough is 10,000
killed in 30 days enough War indeed is a
virus that always wants to expand then
the current conflict is a wildfire that
could consume the region that could
spread delegates discussed ways to
reestablish food water electricity and
medical supplies they also talked about
creating a maritime humanitarian
Corridor France and Italy are already
sending Hospital ships to the region
macr also said Paris would increase a
aid for Palestinians this year from 20
million to more than $100 million for
getting vital Aid into Gaza said M will
only happen if there's an immediate
humanitarian pause in the
fighting civilians must be protected
that's absolutely indispensable and
non-negotiable and is an immediate
necessity the French President hosted
this conference not only to call for
humanitarian pors in the fighting to
help civilians in Gaza but all also to
urge the International Community to work
towards a lasting ceasefire between
Israel and Hamas until now the European
unions back to humanitarian pows but
refrained from calling for an end to the
fighting saying that Israel has a right
to defend itself but as the deaths
increase in Gaza so have calls in the
block to end the Bloodshed Ma's talk of
a ceasefire could signal a change of
Direction in Europe Natasha Butler Al
jazer
Paris make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer